month or so local organizations have
taken steps to support the asian
american community right here in las
vegas
and brian this comes after the mass
shooting in atlanta that killed six
women of asian descent
as well as other attacks all across the
country reporter kate houston shows how
a local martial arts business is
providing
empowerment through self-defense we were
able to
gain skills to protect ourselves and at
least
being aware of our surroundings edelweis
solano is one of more than a dozen
people that came out to the las vegas
kung fu academy on tuesday
solano joined her colleagues from the
asian community development council
to learn self-defense and how
situational awareness can impact
safety even though we all have common
sense we have a tendency to be
distracted
in a lot of areas so we want to make
them aware that that distraction can be
very
dangerous in their their life
instructor denise gonzalez walked the
group through different techniques of
how to get out of a grip
and how to fight back she also
demonstrated important tools for
self-defense such as pepper spray and
personal alarms
it's not living in fear it's basically
learning the tools to be able to be
more aware have more confidence
and to protect yourself for students
like bethany tan
these classes have not only helped her
gain physical skills but confidence in
herself
when i first started actually i was like
super quiet super shy i would i wouldn't
really talk to anyone so being here has
really learned to
help me learn to boost my confidence and
just kind of get out there more
the academy currently has a lot of kids
in its courses but would like to see
more adults and seniors learning
self-defense
kate houston 8 news now the academy says
some crimes against the asian community
go
unreported they're telling the public
that if they see something
say something denise